so hi my name is Jacob I'm from h2o AI
anybody heard of this company before
perfect so I'll be talking about our
integration of h2o inspired let me start
with who we are it's actually just me
here but I always mentioned to people
because it's kind of important
I'm Jacob or kuba I'm suffering here
h-2a I I'm from Czech Republic and I
work on sparkling water mainly these
days and there is also Micheal he's
current the VP of engineering at h-2a I
and why I mention him is because he's
the creator of sparkling water he
doesn't work on his project much anymore
but he's the mind behind this project so
what I'm gonna talk about is how in h2o
we try to handle a missionary life cycle
because it's not just about training the
time in the model it's about also the
monitoring the model in production it's
also about the artifacts we use for the
for the production lines in with the
models which 2sp use and so on
so before I start talking it in more
details about h2o and Apache spark I
will just quickly introduce the abstract
life cycle which we need to handle in
our machine learning task everyday so
basically first we have some data in
data legs and we need to process the
data we need to load the data first and
do some teacher engineering on data
cleansing so the first books we can
think of it that we will take some data
from the multiple data sources and it
will join the date I'll use some basic
data cleansing then if you want to train
some morals be my do some feature
engineering we might do it manually or
we might use some tools which I'm also
gonna show later which can do that for
us so we do some feature engineering and
after that we need to turn the algorithm
it can be simple simple simple process
which will just transform the data it
can be iterative process taking symbols
any outer melt ask which will basically
find the best model of it any given
constraints for you basically anything
what can build a model for you
but this is not the end you just get
yourself the model which is actually the
easy easy part these days we have lots
of tools we can use and getting the
model is kind of easy
the interesting bit starts with
deploying the model so what we need to
do we need to also apply we need to take
this some simple data it can be from it
can be coming from your web page or user
clicks user clicks on something you get
you get a some simple data you need to
run predictions on you need to run the
feature ization on those data as well
you need to clean cleaner data as well
and then you can learn the predictions
on the model artifact you just created
so this is the whole lifecycle which we
need to tackle without any tools
mentioned so far and I'm gonna mention
these implementations on two
implementations the first one is using
spark in h2o which is our integration
which we call it sparkling water and
basically h2o is also our product it's
open source it's a machine on a platform
it's cluster based and you can run any
kind of algorithm you want such as GBM
deep learning all the stance algorithms
and in this tool we try to integrate h2o
with Apache spark so smart people can
actually use it nicely without worrying
how h2o works internally they so they
they can just use the the API standard
to spark users the second information we
use values driverless AI again in spark
about the environment but I will get to
that later in both implementations we
have the people deployed deployed a
pipeline in form of spark pipeline and
be used different to artifacts for the
model in the first implemented show mojo
in the second in variant h2 drivers area
module what is that I will get to that
later as well
so the first in donation is h2 and spark
sparkling water what is it
so I already introduced h2o elevate it's
actually for special presentation to
induce h2o properly so just in two word
two sentences it's machine learning
platform its caster based it was written
from scratch by by our intern engineers
so you can there on
so all for example GBM is completely
paralyzed beat we train different trees
in the front machine so we get your
model of us as possible and we try to be
pretty accurate as well it's all
distributed and it's mainly for machine
learning experts don't get me wrong
even people who are starting with hto
can use this H dou H dou free but
sometimes you need to tune H to a little
bit more to get your to get the perfect
results we have all the tuning you can
there is like 50 arguments you can set
up for GBM for example so if you want to
get best model you need to know what
you're doing you need exon data
scientist which can do the best tooling
for you of course it will do some it was
select some nice default it will work
but you might not get the best model so
there is some expertise needed in this
case and sparkling water just integrates
this ecosystem this h2o intense park
echo system is anybody here using spark
perfect that's for people who don't use
spark spark is basically a platform
which is used for processing data in
parallel distributed para distributed
platform for processing your data so we
use partly motor to connect these two
these two these two applications and how
this original the abstract the abstract
slide looks like in this example
implementation the first the first part
is done in spark so we use part to load
the data to the defintiely do the
feature engineering in spark and then we
switch to h2o always wrapped inside one
application which is called sparking
water in h2o we do the model training we
just need to it's a technical detail we
just need to switch to data format when
you go from spar to h2o but we have a
helper metals for that and when we go to
production ization we use just par type
line we don't have to have h to run time
or day we don't have to h to cluster
available at this point which kind of
helps because you want help you want to
have your production pipeline kind of
have easy easy as possible and introduce
another class of solution in operation
as the pipeline can slow things down so
this is pure sparklin and we use spark
pipelines which is a nice concept you
can write several several steps in into
one one artifact let's say you load the
data you apply a few transformations and
you you train the model and you can
specify all this in one single pipeline
which is one artifact which you can
share amongst your data scientists so
it's on scatter around and this pipeline
contains inside h2o mucho model which is
the the artifact which stores
information about the training model
from h2 so this was kind of struct let
me just show you a quick two minutes
demo how this will look in a practice
can you see it should I make a bigger at
the end just raise your hand if you can
see it I will make it bigger is it
better
perfect so this will be a quick demo I'm
not gonna be running it I'll just go
through it this is a simple demo where
we take some data and we will create
some part pipeline the data are simple
VF another tool called reverse AI and
this data contains information about how
long the drivers a I took to train the
model based on specific configuration so
let's say if you have had your data of
mullet one balloon of rose it had 10
features
it was Windows or Linux went very you
turn the later so we have these columns
and we try to predict how long this our
internal to to to train the model but
the data is not important here so I'm
just I'm gonna just so spark here I'm
just gonna do some technical technical
details I'm gonna import PI sparkling
which is our Python vapour for sparkling
water I'm gonna make sure that h2 is
running inside of that spark cluster so
I can use h2o models inside of this
spark in a spark a stir
this is just some details about the
class so I'm using OneNote I'm running
locally you can also go to our user
interface which is nice that you don't
have to write any code you can just
click turn in your model on your
predictions in the in the flow but the
important part is that is the spark
pipeline how we define it so the first
the box 24 specify the first pipeline
stage this is called SQL transformer
stage and what it actually does it will
select it will select all the older rows
where number of rows in the training
media set was was higher than 100 we are
not interested in small small small runs
of that drivers are too I mentioned a
while ago so this is a simple SQL
transformer the second transformer is
provided by h2o the API is very similar
to the spark one and what it does it
will actually run outer ml inside of
this pipeline so I don't need to
actually specify much I just say another
pipeline stage is h2o 2 ml I'm gonna
give it 60 seconds it won't do any any
extraordinary model with it in this 60
seconds but it will do something I'm
gonna handle unknown categorical closed
as well so if it sees unknown
categorical you know prediction date in
your data for predictions it will it
won't die it will just Angeles na I'm
mentioning the prediction column t total
here I'm just defining the hope I plot
the pipeline so I'm just mentioning the
two two pipeline stages you know one
single pipeline here I'm loading the
data by Rita mama is the simple simple
latest at which I mentioned before about
the internal runs of the drivers AI I
need to convert the data to spark rain
because these pipelines are designed to
work nicely with Apache spark so you
don't you can use spark frames you don't
have to use h2o frames but the thing I
used H
H to import fella is because H do spend
a lot of time on improving the parsers
so we can infer the datatypes pretty
nicely so that's why I prefer to use H
so import file because we know we can
even on small data sets we can we can do
a nice work inferring the scheme schema
and types so here I converted the data
to spark frame and I just I'm just gonna
call fit method on the pipeline what it
actually do does is that it will go
through all the pipeline stages and it
will apply them on this data so it will
first filter the rows the rows which I
don't want to have in the in the in the
in the model and then it will train the
model so it's actualized and you can
store this pipeline on this in your
database it works in the serialize
pipeline works in our Python Scala so
it's a language independent and then I'm
just saving the pipeline here what you
can also do on this model you can call
Modelo transform and you can give it
prediction data I'm gonna run it and
other nation what this will actually
does it will again go through all these
stages but for the production ization so
we have the nice artifact which is good
for both model building and
proximalization the same model now let
me go back to slides
so this was a quick demo of how this
works in sparkly motor and now I'm gonna
you show the very similar thing using
each to reverse a I in sparkling water
so all this before was open source you
can use h2o sparkling water spark for
free me don't charge anybody for this
all the features available are there you
can just download from github or from
our page actual dermis is a closed
source product but it's another
alternative
I mentioned h2o to ml before and it's
actually what it does it's it will it
tries to find the best motor within the
given constraints h2o drivers is kinda
another lab it brings out animal to
another level and we try to do feature
transformations also for you
automatically so you don't have to
figure out which columns I need to split
what kind of emergency due to give to
get myself the best model
so this tools is good for beginners or
for people who don't want to spend time
on data science they just want to get
best model they don't care how it's done
we of course provide all the tools like
intervertebral eteri we can it's all
there but if you don't want to spend
time on tuning the models taking care of
features you can use this this tool
there is no expected knowledge from from
you so it kinda replace your data
scientists and there is automatic
feature engineering why it's this
possible we have lots of people from
Kegel in H dough who spend a lot of time
on tuning the tuning the receives for
drivers AI so V for example know if it's
time series we can apply specific
transformations we have the we try to
get the domain knowledge inside of
drivers AI for the specific data sets
how the implementation looks like in
this in this context in this case each
we use purchased for the direct data
cleansing and dermis AI for all feature
engineering and
training the implement the production as
a shield pipeline is very similar we
again use spark to production eyes this
data using this part pipeline what
actually that was AI does it will it
will create artifact which is called h2o
mojo pipeline which we can also use
inside of spark pipeline so at the end
we have one single unit one single
artifact which is the same for previous
ocean and this solution which we can
deploy just a quick demo have traversed
AI looks like I'm gonna make it bigger
as well okay so really really super
quick demo I have this tool which I I
floated the days under here I can click
on predict its way I just need to select
the target the response column and I
have a free knobs here accuracy time and
interpretability I also enable GPUs by
default so it will use GPUs if you have
them and what actually does these knobs
echo is how much how how much you wanna
do your model to be accurate if you
decide to be really accurate the model
training will take more time we need to
decide what transformation speak and you
speak and use some specific
transformations in this case the same
for time if we give it more time we can
use more complex transformations more
iterations when it comes to
interpretability
if we won't have freely interpreted by
the again can't use all the features all
the feature transformations because it
kind of some feature transformations we
use are not that nicely interpreted by
humans so for example in banks or
insurance companies you need to really
be able to explain somebody how your
model reasoned how which path it choose
so we take care about that if I just
launched the experimental it will start
it will start working this will take
around 20 minutes half an hour so I'm
gonna wait for the result
but when it's finished it will give us
h2 a mucho pipeline file which we can
use inside of that spark spark pipeline
so this is just in case I wouldn't be
able to run these levers yeah this is
just a sneak peek into both feature
transformations are actually we are
actually doing inside of there was a I
this is the full graph on I don't know
how many features is there maybe 100 but
this is kind up something what we as
human can can process these interactions
so that's why we have this tool for us
which can find all the interactions with
these features and tries to give us the
best model of course it's oh I didn't
mention it's actually a co sauce product
but for academia is free so if you are
for academia you can play it for free
for eternity and we have also free
licenses before I spend time on this I
just want to show you how we can
actually production-wise it so this will
just start running I will show you the
script afterwards what I had is what I
prepared here is a small script we just
which takes these to spark pipelines the
one for sparkling water and h2o and the
one for drivers air in sparkling water
and it will it will start reading some
s3 buckets where we put our data
periodically from h2o and it will run
predictions on them in the real time it
will take some time like half a minute
to initialize and then it will start
turning predictions in the you time I
will show you the code in a bit but all
is in the repository so it's it's easier
to go to the repo and have a look on it
so I can see that it just works you need
to believe me on this I don't have
enough time to show you the full code
base but I just wrote a simple script
which fetch the data from a spree bucket
and learns the predictions using this
part and I was AI sparking water
pipelines
I just want to show you
the code behind it because it's actually
kind of easy the first the first spark
pipeline using the H 2 and H 2 and spark
I load it as this these are just
technical details I'm not going to spend
time on this so you use part metal
pipeline model and you can load you can
load you can load a spark pipeline in
the second example I just need to use
specific helper method which will turn
the drivers AI mucho pipeline into spark
pipeline so at this moment I have the
module 1 and module to both these both
these bogus identifiers represents the
same the spark pipelines different on
the implementation but from the API
point of sense it's the same and to to
paralyze it it's actually super simple I
just use Park spark streaming data sets
I just specify the location of the of
the of the data where we are putting
them I will I will specify the input
data stream as the parameter to transfer
method and I will start everything I
will start processing data by calling
the start method on the output leaders
scene so I have just these three lines
is duplicated because we have to because
we have two pipelines I just need to
write these three lines of code to
actually productionize this pipeline to
start eating data from SPE HDFS a sure
running partitions and storing it
somewhere I'm just bending it on the on
the console of course just to just a
side note you can also personalize h2o
models outside of spark environment that
might be helpful for example in some
real time use cases where spark spark
visible the spark ization is just big
much overhead for forcing one line of
one line of data on your input but it's
again for a different talk this is just
how easy can you you can do it in spark
environment okay I still have three
minutes so that's perfect
so I mentioned the basic machine machine
learning lifecycle but it's not
everything you can see that this is the
same slide as at the beginning except
these free free another extra steps here
I'm gonna go through them in a in a
short time so in order to a pre life
full machine life cycle it's not just
enough to put our models somewhere and
run it we should be able to auto
document the model such as people there
is lots of companies which are trying to
do that these days for example which
configuration you use to run your model
which you see the model which which you
see the model hat basically there is no
need for us to do it manually this
should be done automatically there is a
result should be stored in some database
and we should be able to run some meter
search over this data the model
management again when we create some
nice model we should be out of out we
should store it somewhere automatically
if you have big company you have lots of
data scientists training your different
models and there might be one super
amazing model which somebody created but
one week after you just don't know which
which configuration they used so this
will also help and what we are also
working on in h2o is the model
monitoring so when you have the model in
production already we need to be would
like to apply some monitoring steps such
as example is you have a simple model
binomial model which are which are
reading data from some webpage and the
distribution might for example change
from at the beginning it was 50 50
percent it might change to 80 percent to
20 and this this basically this should
trigger something because either your
model is wrong or the data change
significant to significantly so we need
to we need to handle the situation so
the monitoring can actually help us with
that it should be independent on the
specific data
should be able to apply it as another
step and the pipe on with pipe at the -
which is used for production izing
should know about the monitoring as well
and with this witness witness
implemented it's actually kind of low
before we should be able at the end to
train the model for rationalize it store
all the details to some databases for
further research and then if we find
some changes in incoming data we can
actually automatically return in the
model and start the loop again this can
be done all automatically in the future
but we are still are not yet there so it
was kind of quick I'm sorry that I was
speaking that quick but that's it you
can find lots of materials here so you
can just take picture of it or the link
points to the same page so there are
links to h2 in sparkling water and just
to wrap it up so sparkling water is -
which combines the power of h2 and spark
and it can be used to productionize h2o
models from h2 a free open source
product and also driverless AI darvis
air - thank you thanks
[Applause]
any questions hi how you compare the
spare ml with the h2 l yeah so the
question was how how we compare spark ml
to h2o algorithms so that's a tricky
question and I'm gonna answer that in a
specific numbers but we believe that we
can do a bit better than spark ml we
think that this a little bit behind the
the answer I want to give is that we
don't have our own benchmarks but there
is a guy called silard vodka from Poland
and he does open source benchmarks of
different tools such as Parkin lh2 oh
he's not affiliated to h2 at all so if
you know have a look how we compare
these data sets
I would I would suggest looking at the
edit repository because if he would
provide some benchmarks it just doesn't
make sense
everybody food think that we just tune
it to look good for h2 here either
got him Jim general h2o questions but I
noticed I've never seen H hasn't really
gotten into deep learning very much is
there a reason for them license for
driverless IAI okay so there are two
questions first one first one was about
departing in h2o whether we still
support it maternal so we still have a
deep learning in h2o the basic one but
we don't support complex neural networks
in h2 fever the head project called deep
water which were integrating H so with
tensor flow a mixed net or kapha
platforms but what we realized is that
there is no point of competing with
these tools for example tens of always
amazing and it does great job and why
should we spend time on doing something
about somebody already working on
great job so if you want to use complex
neural networks I would say go to these
tools there is basic information there
is also implementation of deep learning
h2o but it might not be as complex as
tensorflow
for example and the second question is
how we handle licenses in driverless AI
so the RS is closed source product it's
a free for academia so if you are
student or teacher you can get it for
free for a limited time you can get a
free three weeks license to start to
play with it and then you need to talk
to our sales team what we can do next
for you now did I answer your question
yeah it's a br really it this is this is
always customer specific in h2o we don't
have like specific guidelines we always
try to make every customer happy as much
as possible so we don't have specific
guidelines specific steps what for for
this process it's really customer
customer specific yes indirect less AI
when you're done with the model is that
like a black box that you can just take
a face value or if you actually got the
resource can you go back and and and
take a look at all the details and how
many models were trying and you know the
different results and the comparisons of
the sports I'm talking like that mm-hmm
so if I miss a curricular question most
if it's just the black box or you can
see the model details somehow yeah
yeah so it's not just black box if you
turn the mod if you turn the drivers a
model you get this mojo artifact it's
just a fancy zip file which you can
extract it will contain all the
transformations what we did so you can
actually see in the llamo ml format what
transformations we are executing in
which order what data what are in the
inputs outputs what are the types and so
on so actually when you train the model
it's all transparent for you and when
you finish the model you can also use
ours right to interpret the model so you
can actually see all the details how we
reason about some specific rows one more
question
thank you a wonderful presentation
I was just wondering in the governed ml
lifecycle slide the part about Model
Management is that handled in any way by
sparkling water itself or is that done
kind of externally in spark thank you
and one other thing
do you have any general best practices
advice for model management so right now
we are still working on it
this is not this is just a prototype
image - I don't I don't want to show
anything yet but this video depends on
what you need model management can for
some people it can mean just having a
designated folder then they where they
put their models but this just doesn't
doesn't scale at some point for us we
are thinking of this having some
specific database solution where you can
run some meta search over the models so
you and the models should connect
contain all the artifacts which you need
to productionize the models such as
specific jar files for Java provenance
correction ization item to Spyder
libraries everything basically if
somebody new comes to your company given
them
just quickly production as this model
you don't have to install anything there
and there and there everything should be
at okay this model called a1 all that
all the tools are here and the model is
here so that's how we think about it it
should be self explainable and right now
spark spark itself doesn't do model
management it's all different question
viniq when it comes to data brakes they
they are working on the novel which is
amazing project and they are trying to
solve this task this as well as what we
are trying to do okay I lied final
question not a question but a comment
for the people in the room we're gonna
have a tutorial right after lunch for
two hours where we're gonna be building
a full end-to-end machine learning
project that will go into two products
from h2o to recreate it almost as good
as driverless AI will see we're gonna
see one part where drivers lists AI
would do better and we would want to
have that as well as a another prominent
tool their existential competitor as
well but we're gonna build everything
from beginning to end and operationalize
it and then go deeper into what it means
to say automated machine learning and
not needing data scientists anymore
alright thanks Jacob thank you
[Applause]